what made it time for a brick-and-mortar
like what made it time for a real salon
well I was operating this mobile
business straight at home and and you
know it was it was somewhat of a whim of
an idea there was no like I wasn't
trying to build a big business I was
trying to get away from my kids for a
couple of hours you know during the day
something for myself and because I felt
conversation yeah and and because I had
spent so many years in hair and I was
like this will be like a piece of cake
for me and so how often were you doing
uncommon so I put up my my ex-husband
who's like the creative of Drybar he
made me a one-page website I came up
with the name straight at home which I
was quite proud of I thought it like
really checked all the boxes right
because you're going straight to your
home well straighten your home straight
hair at your home yeah I'll come over
when your baby sleeping I you know I put
up this like one-page website I went to
like all like the mommy groups all over
town and I was like I'll come over while
your baby's sleeping over yoga class
you're like here you go here you go but
what was what was amazing and I think
like the marketer and entrepreneur and
me was so excited to start getting the
calls and that's what happened as I
started getting you know calls to come
to him in home you know woman I didn't
know and I started building up this this
business where I was like I really you
know in theory I don't think I actually
made any money I was charging 40 dollars
a client and between gas and driving off
yeah and like my Nissan Xterra with a
duffel bag in the backseat you know I I
was doing maybe two to three clients a
day like it was nothing yeah but it grew
really fast and I started getting calls
and I really was saying no way more than
I was saying yes because I still had to
pick up my kids from a preschool and you
know I just like every one of the job
was to be flexible yes and so but but
well you know I'm so grateful that I did
that and for that experience because it
so much of that business has informed
what Drybar ultimately became and and I
really realized during that time when I
was saying no to my clients my quitting
my next question to them was always well
what do you do where do you go and
they're like well you know either go to
like the Fantastic Sams like down the
street which they hated because like
fighting is bad it's like the experience
inside you don't know what you're
getting or they would go to their cut
and color salon where they're you know
paying upwards of like 75 to 80 bucks
for a blowout you know if not more and
they were like and so I just don't do it
and I was like well that's a shame
you know because they loved it and when
they did it and it gave them his extra
boost of confidence they are really
happy and so that's when I went to my
brother who's involved and has no
business in the hair world and said you
know I want to turn my mobile business
into a brick-and-mortar and this was
2010 so or almost 2010 it was in the
middle of a recession yeah most yeah
what most women got the idea that most
men were like this is the craziest thing
like even my brother's first response
was like why would a woman pay somebody
else to blow out their hair now this is
10 years ago and I feel like men are a
lot more savvy about blowouts now but
but even still men are like what what's
a blowout but women got it and I mean
man we had to we had to personally
guarantee that first lease in Brentwood
because the landlord was like hey
everybody was like what the hell is this
concept and my brother my brother had
worked in real estate marketing and he
had a good friend who was an architect
this Harvard award-winning architect who
built you know million-dollar homes and
you know he was like my little sister
has an idea for like a hair salon
concept would you do it with us and he
was he was like kind of in between
projects and his name is Josh I learned
he still to this day ten years later
builds all our stores but that's cool he
was and we couldn't afford and we gave
him a little bit of equity and in a way
we went and boom and it was just this
crazy thing and I remember going to
Brentwood I thought about this and so
long but I remember going to Brentwood
when we were under construction and the
shopping center was dead like there just
was there was nobody in sight no women
nothing and my brother was like Ali when
the [ __ ] where art where is everybody
and I was like they're gonna come it's
like we will go and sure enough you know
the first day we open we were booked
solid it was like I mean we hit the
ground running it was so unbelievably it
just totally shows that it's your
calling like it's meant to be it's it's
you in the flow of like what was needing
to happen you're feeling into it and
like you trust it you had to believe
right I mean I did I mean and I think
that you know the the you know this the
phrase ignorant is bliss very much alike
to me
you know I've I've always been a little
bit in the clouds like I don't really
I'm really
bad about knowing what's going on in the
world in the news and I don't I've never
paid super close attention that I'm not
super proud of that but it's just who I
am and when when we were looking at that
participation and everybody was like
you're crazy
also a lot of people told me the actual
space we were looking at at Brentwood I
remember a woman kind of summe being
like you know every business that's been
here has failed I was like boom thanks
for that yeah we're not going to and I
was like I really believe at least in my
little world in LA and the clients I had
I really believed that women would pay
$35 to look really great and I thought
that they would probably go longer in
between cuts in color because they kind
of camouflage it with a really great
blowout right and that was it that was
my belief and that was my dream and that
was my hope and don't ever have around
you leaving
[Music]
you